now at 11 a huge demand for testing is
hundreds lined up today at unlv's
covid19 drive-through site it caused a
traffic nightmare on tropicana and
university center drive thanks so much
for joining us tonight i'm sasha loftis
it's been a long night especially for
the people who were stuck in those lines
madison kimbrough spoke with many of
them this evening she joins us live with
more madison
sasha i've been to this site numerous
times and i've never seen it as busy as
it was now people getting back from
celebrating the holidays saying this is
definitely not how they wanted the start
of 2022 to look
it's very scary to see the line like
this it makes me think that we might
need to shut down again it's a new year
but unfortunately the coronavirus has
not slowed down with the omicron being
the fastest spreading variant thus far
people are flocking to testing sites
like this one at unlv's paradise campus
to get their drive through test and all
the people we spoke to have been waiting
in line for hours this is crazy because
i've gotten
a few tests before and i've never seen
the lines like this i've usually gotten
in and out really quick i was um
like you know pretty sure it was going
to take like five to ten minutes but i
did not expect the lines to be this long
i've been waiting here for about like
two hours 30 minutes ever since 5 30.
katie lee who plans on visiting family
in the next couple days says she hasn't
been able to get tested anywhere and
this was her last resort i have been to
urgent care i have called every
walgreens in town i cannot find a rapid
test or pcr test i got in line at
four
and it's taken four hours for me to get
this close sunday's testing site opened
at 5 30 pm and due to the large amount
of people organizers started to shut
down the line by 8 30. those who made it
past the entry point had until 10 30 to
get tested if everybody would have just
gotten on board and understood the
social responsibility of getting this
vaccine so it didn't you know multiply
and mutate
this could have been avoided
this testing site on unlv's paradise
campus is open sunday through thursday
if you plan on coming out this week it's
probably best that you get in line
around 4 30 in the afternoon reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now